this week's mini election trip i'm off
to canvey island in essex to speak to
10-acre continue kips general election
laws he is one of the parties rising
stars until recently writing that
manifesto but he's now focusing on
paternity and peek in the window seat as
long if there's one message the with
some of you kids campaign what is it
believe in Britain vote you Kip and get
you Kip we've seen here all over the
south as its coast that when people vote
York if they get you Kip the fantastic
results we got to you in the county
council elections pull it up by the
European elections and district council
elections we're on a roll in South Asia
we're a positive party we want to have a
proper immigration system on Australia
the point system so you get the best and
brightest from the world but we do not
have an open door to alpha billion
people in the European Union tell me
about your seat in thermic way of
running and I'm sure you're not going to
agree to this but it is one of the top
targets each one was likely seats that
you are going to win and what do you
make of your to count your two
opposition candidates Polly Billington
and them Jackie Doyle price well our
campaign is just about what you keep is
doing for the residents we've got a good
strong team of counselors which I'm one
of them everyone a by-election in
December and we talk about what actually
focuses on the local communities there's
lots of problems with social housing and
the council not putting in the necessary
repairs we're going really microwave
them with bus services to show that we
can deliver for residents and to win
their trust and support for me how do
you think your campaign is better than
the label Tories campaigned for work we
don't stop we keep talking about the
issues we actually are there
twenty-four/seven to take calls from
residents to make sure that repairs are
done that people have a representative
to go to I mean I'm getting calls from
people in outside my ward where they've
got issues they need addressing that
their counselors red or blue simply
aren't putting the working and finally
you were writing new clips manifesto you
were head of policy i believe and you're
no longer doing that well was it did you
quit or were you sacked no I decided
that we heard
good strong policy platform that we
launched a conference we had 90 policies
on the website wasn't much policy here
today though there was no way we've
talked about everybody talks about theme
us as a policy we talked about ending
hospital car parking charges now that
might not be a big issue for Westminster
politicians and Westminster journalists
biosuit hospital car parking charges
have gotten up from two pounds 23 pounds
and that matters a lot of people a lot
of people here are still hurting not
seeing the bright shoots of economic
recovery that the conservatives are
talking about and that matters a lot so
we did cover a lot of ground we have got
a broad policy platform which is n Evans
will turn into a fantastic manifesto and
are you still involved in policy at Orly
just letting them get on with it well
I'm there to help as and when but my
focus now is on delivering for my
community and Thorin and if you become
an MP will you step down as a counselor
and MEP oh well you can't it's illegal
to be an mep look at other MP but I
think with regards to the council I I
can actually get things done as a
counselor you know MPs when they you
know because some MPs just slug off the
council left right and center but
actually working with the council and
being a counselor you can get things
done so assume I look at doing both at
the same time Phillip polar bear makes a
good crack of it doesn't it that's it
that this would stop on the mini
election tour join me next week to see
how the election is being fought for
different part of the country find out
more at mini election co uk